[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport sur TV 78 l'émission ne
surtout pas manqué si vous êtes un
passionné de sport local aujourd'hui
comme toujours il y aura des analyses
techniques des décryptages et surtout
une dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau et ils se sont
préparés comme jamais pour cette
émission présentation en musique de
cette magnifique équipe équipe on
commence à ma droite musique il vient
tout juste d'atterrir à l'aéroport
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on le dit à chaque émission le monde
entier tente de nous le piquer notre
Italian lover Grégory canalet est avec
nous pendant une bonjour Michael oh la
piélo bonjour à tous
moi aller que que Pierre vous avez
compris un Grégory il nous emmène pas en
vacances avec lui mais il y aura
d'autres
rendez-vous on passe de l'autre côté à
musique c'est un petit nouveau il est
l'heure sa deuxième
c'est sponsoring je vais arriver à le
dire chez Orange en Île-de-France il
adore le sport et notamment le rugby et
le football mais il s'y connaît dans
tous les sports vous allez voir il va
vous impressionner Philippe volak nous
fait l'honneur de venir dans cette
émission bonjour à toutes et à tous
Comment allez-vous Philippe ça va j'ai
une dent contre quelqu'un mais enfin
contre personne sur le sur le plateau
mais bon j'ai une petite chic donc mais
ça va aller un petit problème
vous êtes en forme 2e série sélection
pour vous aujourd'hui
on ne compte pas
on termine de l'autre côté musique c'est
un monument dans cette émission notre
Machu Picchu notre Colisée notre Big Ben
l'émission ne serait pas pareil sans lui
il va nous régaler une nouvelle fois
aujourd'hui coach Genlis ex-entrepreneur
de plaisir est avec nous
Machu Picchu moi aussi j'ai une petite
mais pas là
on passera les détails on passera les
détails je vais me préparer aussi j'ai
tout révisé impeccable
à la Frontera
alors
avant donc il a commencé un très fort
aujourd'hui on le voit on va parler de
football américain et des débuts assez
compliqué les Templiers d'Élancourt dans
le championnat de 2e division ils ont
perdu le premier match de leur saison
contre les Léopards de Rouen sur le
score de 23 à 6 et ils ont ensuite perdu
sur tapis vert faço caïman du Mans à
domicile la raison ils n'ont pas trouvé
de médecins pour jouer le match le score
est donc de 18 à 0 pour le moment ils se
sont rattrapés en faisant un match
amical avec les joueurs sur place un
match amical qu'ils ont perdu 21 à 20
pour l'instant les Templiers sont
dernier de la poule eux qui visent la
montée en fin de saison la question sur
cette thématique un mauvais début de
saison condamne-t-il forcément une
équipe oui ou non
non pour vous Grégory non pour vous Jean
oui pour vous Philippe et non pour vous
pierre on va faire un petit duel entre
Grégory et vous Philippe Philippe vous
commencez vous êtes seul contre tous
seul contre tous ça commence donc
je pense pas que ça je pense pas que ça
condamne sa condamne mais bon ils ont
malheureusement ils ont perdu deux
matchs dont un sur tapis vert ils ont
gagné que deux matchs amicaux avant
contre 2D 3 donc c'est pas non plus
les trois dernières années ils sont sur
trois demi-finales je crois en plus
trois demi-finales ils ont toujours à la
limite ils sont toujours ou pas c'est un
peu un peu limite bon c'est sûr que
comme ça deux matchs mais bon le Rouen
c'est quand même les c'est quand même
les une grosse équipe quoi une grosse
écurie quand même après caïman on peut
pas savoir ce que c'est mais je pense
qu'ils étaient prenables s'ils avaient
joué contre contre eux mais c'est
méchant oui c'est méchant caïman c'est
quasiment les meilleurs et vraiment je
pense que non il faut attendre encore
encore attendre voir les deux prochains
matchs et là je pense que là ça peut ça
peut être
pas forcément il y a 10 matchs en tout
dans la saison régulière à jouer alors
oui c'est pas le départ escompté c'est
pas le départ
de défaite en images mais il en reste 8
du coup pour se qualifier pour les
playoffs donc on ne parle pas encore
monter mais de playoff pour se réserver
le droit de jouer une place aller
pourquoi pas en finale et monter en D1
c'est tout le mal qu'on peut leur
souhaiter je vais j'ai du mal par contre
oui c'est sûr que dans les têtes
peut-être que ça va peser le fait
d'avoir perdu sur tapis vert en plus
pour leur retour à domicile à voir
comment ça les impactera sur sur le
reste de la saison maintenant il en
reste 8 matchs à jouer rien n'est joué
encore dans cette division 2 casque d'or
Jean qu'est-ce que vous en pensez non
moi j'étais de la vie de degrés Philippe
vous a pas mais surtout qu'il a dit
d'aller changer
il a fallu comprendre la question parce
qu'il a dit que finalement ils étaient
pas condamné il a dit non pour il
démarre juste Philippe la vie Rouen est
une des grosses écuries de la poule de
la poule et le deuxième bien sûr sur ce
tapis vert là c'est vraiment c'est une
grosse erreur pour moi c'est une grosse
erreur puisque c'est une histoire de de
de médecin
aujourd'hui donc là voilà donc là c'est
vraiment une grosse
erreur c'est même pas du sportif là
c'est une erreur administrative là il y
a de quoi
je pense pas que ça va les affecter sur
le restant du championnat c'est il doit
être en colère sur le sur le moment mais
bon après
8 matchs 8 matchs c'est les combien ils
sont qualifiés les quatre premiers les
deux premiers je crois les deux premiers
deux premiers bon les deux premiers ça
va être un petit peu plus compliqué mais
parce que bon quand on perd deux matchs
oui oui bien sûr
il reste 8 matchs rien n'est c'est pas
dit qu'il soit condamné c'est c'est pas
moi de départ ils ont ils ont plus trop
droit on va dire à l'erreur maintenant
c'est ça pierre plutôt team Greg et Jean
pour le la condamnation pas forcément
automatique elle va après de défaite
mais je me souviens de tous les débats
qu'on a fait en début de saison sur les
Templiers des longs courts on en parle
souvent parce que c'est une équipe qui
nous qui nous tient à cœur ça faisait
longtemps qu'on avait qu'on les avait
pas vu évolué parce qu'il y a une
interruption plus ou moins longue avec
avec ses années de covid et là on est un
peu sur du bis répétita avec des
démarrages poussifs beaucoup beaucoup de
volonté de bonne volonté de l'ensemble
des interlocuteurs qui prennent la
parole notamment sur ce plateau et ce
qui est ce qui mène au destinées des
Templiers et puis
loupe la première marche je suis de la
ville de Jean aussi louper la deuxième
pour une erreur administrative alors que
a priori tous les calendriers sont bien
établis les choix dans la date sont
également convenu entre tous et
notamment j'ose espérer du médecin aussi
donc là c'est c'est là ça ils peuvent
ils peuvent avoir des regrets si jamais
ça passe pas à un match près sur les sur
les victoires là
avec une défaite les Templiers ne
montent pas en première division c'est
là où on l'a mis j'aurais pu être mitigé
en disant c'est perdre 2 fois
sportivement ça condamne pas fort de
complètement une fois sportivement une
fois administrativement là pour le coup
c'est c'est presque une erreur une faute
professionnelle dans la gestion de la de
la saison de du d'équipe de football
américain donc espérons que ça ne leur
porte pas préjudice à la fin de cette
saison c'est l'enfant plus un 18-0 hein
donc peut-être que ça peut aussi peser
dans la balance à la fin c'est lourd et
ils ont aussi un nouveau joueur
américain on en a très peu parlé pour
l'instant c'est Ashley Brooks parce
qu'on n'a pas pu le voir jouer un
finalement le le dernier match des
Templiers d'Élancourt un quarterbach
Américain qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
toujours de de faire venir alors on le
connaît pas forcément Ashley Brooks
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de faire
venir des import US comme ça c'était un
petit revirement dans la politique des
Templiers qui
aimer bien ces derniers temps faire
jouer leur propre jeune alors que là ils
font venir un apport US ça faisait un
petit moment qu'ils avaient pas fait
venir des Américains j'ai envie de vous
dire il vient d'un pays forcément le
football américain son nom l'indique est
très très développé il va peut-être
pouvoir apporter une expérience des
choses qui ne se font pas forcément en
France des choses un peu différentes
maintenant si c'est au détriment comme
vous le dites Michael de jeune qui était
prometteur et qui avait peut-être un peu
plus leur mot à dire sur le terrain
qu'un apport us on va dire la saison
nous le dira le reste de la saison nous
le dira ça peut être à qui tout de si
effectivement c'est un super joueur bah
là on pourra pas notamment de Sean
Shelton qui avait réussi à propulser les
Templiers parmi les meilleures équipes
européennes
là il
occupe quand même le poste clé au fond
de l'américain ils prennent les postes
clés pour les
politiques la politique peut rester la
même parce qu'il faut venir un joueur
des États-Unis que ça a changé leur
politique globale du club il est certain
quand même qu'à ce poste-clé quoi
torback il faut quand même quelqu'un qui
qui sait de quoi il parle quoi si si on
a ici si on a un ensemble de pizzas
si on a Giorgio le pizzaïolo ça va
peut-être pas le faire donc c'est vrai
que il faut il faut quand même un gars
qui qui est une pointure quoi on l'avait
dit on l'avait dit à 15 jours à peu près
ils ont besoin et je crois que le
football américain d'une manière
générale a besoin d'apport de qualité
sur et de l'expérience en fait de
l'expérience des Américains sur leur sur
leur sport on va dire leur sport comme
vous l'avez appelé et et donc
sur un poste clé et de temps en temps
sur une des pièces maîtresses de
l'effectif je pense qu'il peut apporter
une expérience et justement que ça
puisse profiter à des petits jeunes qui
vont se pouvoir se lancer après derrière
la seule chose ensuite c'est que la
saison est assez courte et donc les
feuilles de match là aussi peut-être
peut-être match finalement à discuter
même si ça bouge beaucoup si ça bouge
beaucoup au football américain en
attaque défense mais là là pour le coup
je pense que ça peut vraiment leur
apporter l'expérience je crois que c'est
la conférence qui est la plus relevée en
plus je crois bien alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de livinois Jean-Pierre Garcin
qui a terminé 16e du dernier Dakar nous
parlerons aussi de la pépite du basket
français livre Linois Victor webmanama
est-il prêt pour la NBA mais avant de
parler de ces thématiques on va parler
de rugby
[Musique]
un petit son voilà en hommage à Jean a
peut-être c'est votre son genre c'est
votre partie alors on va commencer cette
page rugby par un résultat c'était le
choc à ne pas manquer dans les Yvelines
en Fédérale 2 Versailles recevait
plaisir pour un derby qui s'annonçait
sulfureux entre deux équipes dans le top
6 de la poule un beau duel qui a tourné
à l'avantage du PRC sur le terrain des
versaillers le score 30 à 19 vers ça y
est Versailles a réussi à tenir une
mi-temps tenant un échec c'est
Plaisirois 16 partout avant de craquer
en seconde période votre avis tout
simplement Pierre Chevalier sur cette
rencontre
je l'ai vécu je l'ai vécu une si tu et
dire que la logique finalement était
respectée deux choses la première c'est
que c'est que par rapport au match aller
qui avait été d'une toute autre facture
où là pour le coup on avait pris assez
cher à plaisir
on a montré les Versailles ont montré un
autre visage sur la réception de la
réception plaisir et la deuxième c'est
la deuxième chose c'est une question
assez assez large d'expérience vraiment
d'expérience dans cette dans cette
Fédérale 2 dans cette poule là on va en
particulier plaisir y est depuis six
plus de 6 saisons maintenant avec
clairement des matchs gagnés des matchs
perdus des saisons au couteau où il se
battent pour ne pas descendre et ils
réussissent à ne pas descendre
Versailles c'est ça c'est la première
saison des des bleuets blancs à ce
niveau là donc là ça a été une ça a été
une opposition à la fois d'expérience et
de style je retiens que à la mi-temps le
score était de parité à 16 16 et on
avait vraiment
bien tenu notre rond et après il y a eu
il y a eu des changements assez assez
déterminants et tactique côté plaisir et
ça a basculé au fur et à mesure au fur
et à mesure du de la deuxième mi-temps
en faveur des plaisirs rois
on peut dire que la logique a été
respectée
depuis ce match là il y a eu dimanche
dernier une belle victoire aussi pas
très pas très net mais de deux points de
Versailles contre Ris-Orangis un autre
gros de la poule donc faire ça grandit
voilà versa grandit à qui de
l'expérience et découvert un nouvel
objectif sur cette première saison celui
d'aller chercher une calife ce qui est
pas forcément évident à faire la
première saison la première saison c'est
un groupe qui il y a énormément de
qualité le noyau dur de la saison
dernière est restée quelques apports
bien sentis à quelques postes clés et on
a un groupe qui qui a envie d'aller loin
et qui a envie de faire plus qu'exister
ou de se maintenir dans cette poule de
fédéral 2 genre qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez de cette victoire de plaisir
votre ancien club face à Versailles au
club de votre ami oui tout à fait oui
tout à fait vous avez des amis à plaisir
aussi tout à fait j'ai jamais un peu
partout comme tout le monde
non mais Pierre l'a dit la logique a été
respectée on a une équipe de plaisir qui
je l'ai déjà dit sur ce plateau qui est
maintenant habitué à ce niveau qui a
fait qui a fait ses preuves et qui
maintenant ben je voulais au tableau il
y a aussi quand même ça il faut pas se
il faut pas se le voiler cette nouvelle
formule enfin cette nouvelle création de
de niveau de la Nationale 2 qui a été
créé cette année qui quand même fait à
faire remonter pas mal de clubs et qui a
qui aujourd'hui on dit aujourd'hui la
fédérale 2 n'était pas celle de la
saison dernière ou des saisons d'avant
ça il faut quand même il faut quand même
le le préciser ça permet à une équipe
comme Versailles qui est montante
aujourd'hui de pouvoir prétendre à jouer
la qualification je parle pas de plaisir
parce que le plaisir est une équipe qui
aujourd'hui est à guéri à ce niveau là
et qui est à ça juste position c'est à
dire dans les premiers en haut du
tableau et une équipe qui l'an dernier
avec le même effectif jouer le ventre
mou et une éventuellement une
qualification ils étaient plaisirs à la
place de Versailles cette année donc le
fait que le niveau est légèrement baissé
permet à plaisir de jouer un petit peu
plus et au tableau et j'ai la montée je
dirais maintenant d'avoir des objectifs
différents c'est à dire la montée
j'allais en venir et Versailles qui est
un club montant ben ça leur permet eux
de pouvoir essayer d'accrocher une
qualification moi je suis convaincu que
Versailles se qualifiera parce que ils
ont fait les moyens ils ont mis les
moyens et ils ont fait le recrutement
qu'il fallait
la mayonnaise a appris récemment la
preuve allez le résultat du dernier
match batterie sur Rungis qui est une un
des des cadors de de l'équipe donc c'est
une performance c'est une belle
performance et là ils ont montré qu'ils
existaient et qu'on pouvait compter sur
eux qu'on devait compter sur eux dans la
poule donc ça c'est un peu ça ne peut
laisser entrevoir que de bonnes choses
pour Versailles qui dans la
qualification lui tendent les bras pour
moi alors selon nos informations
Versailles un budget supérieur à plaisir
si je me trompe pas oui si
je dirais oui alors 300000 € environ
pour plaisir d'après mes informations je
sais pas exactement pour pour Versailles
selon la police
c'est un budget qu'on a consolidé grâce
à grâce à de nombreux partenaires locaux
principalement qu'on a consolidé déjà la
saison d'avant
et que qui nous permet d'être oui sur
vos informations au-dessus de celui du
plaisir alors du coup la question sur
cette thématique les moyens financiers
font-ils les performances en rugby oui
ou non
mitigé vous êtes tous mitigés voilà
pierre je vais vous redonné la parole et
ensuite on fera sur le tableau avec
Philippe notamment
un club de rugby amateur j'insiste bien
sur le sur le terme amateur c'est
d'abord des frais de fonctionnement
Versailles c'est un club de 650
licenciés et qui a un budget qui est
notamment notamment fait par un gros
pull des cotisations cotisations et des
licences et les licences de rugby
notamment celle de l'école de rugby et
de nombreux seniors puisqu'on va on va
en gros de l'école de rugby jusqu'au
loisirs notamment avec le rugby à 5 à
toucher et le et les vétérans les Vieux
Crampons que je que je représente
aujourd'hui aussi donc c'est des des
recettes de licence plus le club est
nombreux en terme de licencier meilleur
et le budget mais c'est aussi en phase
des frais de fonctionnement qui sont qui
sont relativement importants de
transport de restauration quand les
quand les équipes se déplacent de
l'inscription au tournoi etc etc pour ça
il faut il faut mettre en face
évidemment des un budget des recettes de
partenariats il faut aussi reconnaître
que de plus en plus dans amateur et on
parlait de la fédérale 2 avec Jean tout
à l'heure tout à fait d'accord
d'ailleurs avec ce nivellement par le
haut qui s'est fait avec la création de
la Nationale 2 puis de la Fédérale 1 et
il a Fédérale 2 qui correspond
maintenant à un niveau de fédéral 3 de
l'année dernière
la poule dans laquelle était Versailles
avec maison Lafitte notamment l'an
dernier donc il y a certains joueurs qui
a certains joueurs qui sont qui sont
défrayés avec certains frais certains
frais qui sont pris en charge par le
club donc voilà ça ça rentre ça rentre
dans le dans le budget global du club on
parle pas de salaire donc c'est pour ça
qu'on parle vraiment d'un gui amateur et
pour ça il faut avoir de la visibilité
et il faut avoir des il faut avoir
des partenariats privés qui représentent
70% de notre budget cette année donc
oui de là à dire que c'est parce que on
a un gros budget qu'on joue la calife ça
serait allé bien vite sur l'essence même
du rugby amateur qui est en fait cette
fameuse mayonnaise dont parlait dont
parlait Jeannot c'est c'est c'est le
faire en sorte que que les joueurs qui
font ça en plus d'un métier qui font ça
en loisir en fait en gros en hobby ou en
loisirs soit heureux de se retrouver à
l'entraînement au match et donc avec un
état d'esprit qui permet avec Solidarité
et on collectif de gagner tous ces
matchs que ce soit de l'école de rugby
en passant par les juniors jusqu'au
c'est jusqu'au seniors donc ça ça
facilite le fonctionnement d'un club ça
ne ça ne détermine pas la réussite de
quelques catégories que ce soit Philippe
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez moi je
pense que au niveau des clubs de des
clubs de rugby à mes scènes c'est très
important parce que le sponsoring c'est
ça représente quand même en moyenne 50%
de 50% de
la manne de la manne financière donc
je sais bien et en plus la billetterie
c'est pas la billetterie c'est pas sur
la billetterie qu'on va qu'on va gagner
qu'on va gagner quelque chose
qu'on va gagner
comme tu disais je veux dire c'est aussi
le coup des licences qui est quand même
qui est quand même élevé le coup de
licences en rugby quand même élevé et je
pense que bon c'est important d'avoir un
mécène il n'y a qu'à regarder tous les
clubs s'ils ont un bon mécène après faut
s'ils sont aussi
par les collectivités locales ou
territoriales c'est important aussi
s'ils sont soutenus aussi comme on voit
dans le dans la poule de de Versailles
et de plaisir
ils ont déclaré forfait général voilà il
manquait aussi de c'est vrai de mes
scènes et c'est un club quand même qui
était quand même
et qui a plongé cette année déjà l'année
dernière il y avait des prémices mais là
il a plongé cette année jusqu'à déclarer
forfait quand même donc c'est quand même
pour le 95 c'était quand même le club le
club phare du 95 je veux dire donc je
pense que c'est important le ouais c'est
important
Grégory bien sûr des moyens conséquents
va faciliter les choses ça va ouvrir des
portes là pour le 4 Versailles pierre
disait tout à l'heure ça a permis de
maintenir les filles qui font place
peut-être de le renforcer ça permet
aussi d'investir sur le futur et de
maintenir ce pôle formation on sait qui
est très important pour le futur et
former les futurs joueurs du club
maintenant l'argent ça mène pas
l'expérience on l'a vu aussi pour
d'autres exemples dans le sport dans le
dans d'autres dans d'autres disciplines
c'est plus les années les matchs les
différents scénarios vivent des matchs
il y a eu un match très difficile à
l’alé face à plaisir là on a vu sur ce
match retour qu'il y avait une vraie
progression cette année pour les
versaillers avec voilà le fait que cette
équipe tienne la dragée haute à plaisir
qui est un habitué de fédéral 2 pendant
une mi-temps et sur la deuxième mi-temps
peut-être s'écrouler à cause de
l'expérience je sais pas mon expérience
je disais peut-être des changements qui
qui ont été qui ont été déterminants
donc oui l'argent facilite les choses
maintenant ça ne fait pas tout
l'expérience vient avec les années
justement
d'expérience voilà sur sur le terrain
genre
le mot de la fin sur cette thématique
ça ne fait pas tout certes mais c'est
essentiel et ça fait la différence quand
même entre un club qui a de l'argent et
une vanne qui ne l'a pas il y a
aujourd'hui les clubs qui peuvent se
permettre d'avoir des gros budgets comme
Versailles qui arrivent en fédéral 2
avec un gros budget par rapport au
niveau avec un gros budget d'ailleurs
supérieur à celui de plaisir qui eux ils
sont déjà depuis 6 ans ça leur permet
simplement de pouvoir aller chercher des
joueurs et qui sont un peu comme tout le
monde parce que c'est de plus en plus le
c'est du rugby amateur certes mais il y
a des défraiements alors on appelle ça
comme on veut mais on a quand même
quelques joues à faire on a quand même
les joueurs aujourd'hui moi qui suis en
train de rugby je sais un petit peu de
quoi je parle les joueurs aujourd'hui
vous parlent un peu plus
souvent et dommage un peu plus d'argent
que que de résultats sportifs le projet
de jeu voilà
sportif donc il est vrai que le fait
d'avoir un petit peu de de budget
dédié à au groupe seniors et aux joueurs
pour les indemnités permet quand même de
pouvoir amener à son groupe des joueurs
meilleurs que si vous avez rien du tout
à donner un joueur si vous avez rien à
lui donner si simplement l'amitié
l'amour la joie bon ben c'est c'est bien
mais on peut pas on peut pas non plus
lui en demander plus que ce qui ne peut
donner donc c'est pas c'est peut-être
pas c'est peut-être pas essentiel mais
ça y contribue largement
voilà donc il en faut et les clubs qui
réussissent sont les clubs qui ont des
budgets moi je pensais que les joueurs
venaient pour vous avant tout genre
c'est une époque j'ai voulu ça une
époque c'était lui-même qui prêchait
beaucoup ça existe encore lui-même mais
pas ce niveau là Fédérale 2
rebondir sur ce que disait greg c'est
c'est sur le timing premier parti du
championnat Versailles se déplace à
Plaisir prend une valise énorme on avait
déjà ces différences de ces de budget là
elles existaient déjà ou du moins dans
ce que disent les interlocuteurs de
plaisir également dans ce qu'on peut
comparer quelques trois mois plus tard
trois mois plus tard match retour c'est
une sportivement à un scénario
complètement différent on perd on perd
au final mais on perd avec les honneurs
et là les budgets n'avaient pas changé
donc c'est simplement pour dire que
c'est aussi dans l'état d'esprit dans
l'humain que qu'évoquait Jean et dans
les besoins aussi dans les besoins
qui sont qui sont couverts par les
mécènes que l'on peut s'épanouir un
joueur au rugby mais ça part aussi par
d'abord une aventure humaine
on va maintenant passer à l'envolée dans
cette émission le moment fort de cette
émission de quoi allez-vous nous parler
Grégory
mais aussi d'un nouveau chapitre qui
s'ouvre on l'espère un beau chapitre
alors pour la première fois depuis 1975
le camp des Loges de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pourrait se
retrouver sans club résidents et pour
cause le PSG va plier bagage à la fin de
la saison pour son tout nouveau centre
d'entraînement à Poissy un écrin de 74
hectares flambant 9 en cours de
finalisation on va en reparler tout à
l'heure seuls quelques matchs des
féminines de l'équipe réserve et des U19
se disputeraient encore au Camp des
Loges mais pas plus l'enceinte sportive
vitrine de Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui va
accueillir la team Grande-Bretagne pour
les JO se retrouverait quelque peu
orphelines mais rassurez-vous une
solution émerge peut-être pour l'avenir
du site un autre club parisien cette
fois-ci de rugby pourrait atterrir être
dans la ville yvelinoise et quel club le
Stade Français actuel deuxième du Top 14
champion de France à 14 reprises
réfléchi à l'opportunité de faire du
Camp des Loges sont un nouveau centre
d'entraînement et des discussions ont
lieu entre les deux parties depuis
quelques mois en spetter wild wild
pardon le propriétaire président et le
directeur général Thomas Lombard ont
déjà visité les installations tout comme
les deux futurs managers du club que
sont Karim guezal et Laurent Labitte
elle l'a fait semble bien engager comme
la confirmer le maire de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye en opéricart à nos
confrères de 7 8actu je le cite nous
avons des discussions sérieuses et
avancées avec le Stade Français nous
devrions je l'espère arriver à une
position dans le courant de la deuxième
quinzaine du mois de février nous sommes
en train de construire un magnifique
projet nous sommes dans les analyses
techniques actuellement dans le sport
français le Stade Français c'est la
deuxième marque après le Paris
Saint-Germain je pense qu'il exagère un
peu on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
mais pour moi c'est une évidence le
Stade Français doit choisir le camp des
Loges ça nous ferait encore plus
d'actualités sportives et de rugby à
commenter et je pense pas que ça va
décevoir mes compères autant de cette
table parler un peu plus de rugby et ça
ne déplairait pas donc à ça ne leur
déplaira pas mais c'est aussi surtout je
pense une bonne solution pour les deux
parties alors pour la ville de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye d'abord l'identité
parisienne entre guillemets du Camp des
Loges et conservé après le Paris
Saint-Germain c'est le Stade Français
Paris qui pourrait venir elle se
consolerait avec l'une des plus grandes
enceintes des plus grandes écuries
pardon du sport français alors le PSG
bien sûr un club de Renault mais là on
parle quand même du deuxième club le
plus titré de l'histoire du rugby
français derrière le Stade Toulousain il
y a une importance sportive donc mais
aussi marketing qui a été développé sous
l'air max Guzzini entre 1992 et 2011 le
rugby spectacle strass paillettes on se
rappelle aussi de quelques matchs au
Stade de France aujourd'hui le Stade
Français c'est plus de 300000 abonnés
sur Twitter quasi 100.000 abonnés sur
Instagram
195000 sur facebook 11000 sur Tik Tok le
réseau social préféré de jambes ils
doivent encore progresser auprès des
jeunes peut-être le Stade Français et
aussi bah avoir le Stade Français au
Camp des Loges pour la ville de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye ça pourrait aussi
et bien générer quelques retombées avec
des supporters qui viendraient sur place
pour observer le Stade Français mais
aussi de l'autre côté pour les soldats
roses du Stade Français je pense que
c'est une belle opportunité c'est avoir
un camp de base aujourd'hui le club
jongle avec plusieurs enceintes les
joueurs s'entraînent au stade Jean-Bouin
ou se dispute également les rencontres
mais qu'ils doivent partager avec les
féminines du PSG et les joueurs du
Football Club de Versailles qui
s'entraîne aussi du côté du stade du
Saut du Loup qui a été rebaptisé
récemment Christophe Dominici et c'est à
Boulogne mais ce complexe est aussi
utilisé par les équipes de jeunes du
club alors le Stade Français
bénéficierait d'une structure de qualité
au Camp des Loges qui était devenu quand
même trop petite pour les joueurs du
Paris-Saint-Germain mais qui sera tout à
fait adapté pour les rugbymen parisiens
le camp des Loges en plus n'est situé
qu'il y a une vingtaine de kilomètres du
stade Jean-Bouin Porte d'Auteuil qui
accueille les rencontres du club
parisien bref j'ai vous dire c'est un
mariage de raison sur le papier mais qui
pourrait devenir un mariage d'amour dans
l'avenir entre la ville de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye les Soldat Rose et
pourquoi pas un jour non plus parler du
Stade Français mais pourquoi pas aller
du stade Saint-Germain je pose ça sur la
table stop
du coup genre on a du mal à vous faire
décrocher apparemment
alors la question sur cette thématique
pour ou contre un déménagement à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye du Stade Français
oui ou non pour ou contre
pour pour ou contre gens vous décidez
allez pour un petit duel avec notre cher
Pierre alors pierre contre ouais contre
parce que je suis je suis très
on en a entendu ça m'énerve pas
forcément mais on est très attentif
évidemment à ce qui se passe dans notre
département quand je dis quand je dis
nous c'est le RC Versailles
je trouve que sur ce plateau comme dans
l'actualité sportive du département on
parle beaucoup finalement de nos voisins
de nos voisins parisiens on a parlé du
PSG avec le avec le Parc des Princes et
cette possibilité déménager à Poissy et
maintenant on parle du Stade Français
Paris qui qui coloniserait le livre
ça vous énerve petit rappel quand même
du sport professionnel vers le sport
amateur le Stade Français Paris a quand
même délogé nos petits copains de la CBB
Boulogne-Billancourt du stade du Saut du
Loup c'est après c'est il leur fallait
il leur fallait une structure assez
proche d'entraînement c'est finalement
c'est finalement Boulogne-Billancourt
qui en a fait qu'on a fait des frais
maintenant la cbbi sont dans une
structure un petit peu plus neuve mais
plus petite qui Alphonse le galop ils
sont dans notre poule donc on en parle
on en parle assez souvent assez souvent
mais c'est une structure du 92 qui avait
été un petit peu est conduite par par
une équipe parisienne certes on n'est
pas dans les mêmes dans les mêmes
proportions dans les mêmes proportions
du sport professionnel de visibilité de
notoriété de marque etc et de niveau
sportif manière générale mais
je suis pas énervé je suis méfiant c'est
à dire que c'est de dire
tant que ça ne va pas au détriment des
équipes du département que ce soit par
des investissements des mises à
disposition de terrain des Yvelines du
département des Yvelines pour des
équipes yvelinoise comme comme
Versailles comme plaisir comme maison
Lafitte par exemple pour ces niveaux là
ça va donc ça va pas à l'encontre là on
a on a plus l'impression que c'est que
c'est un que c'est un parachutage et un
déménagement un peu forcé certes avec un
jeu de chaise musicale puisque le PSG
laisse le camp des loges pour aller pour
aller investir ce ce a priori ce
magnifique écran de Poissy dans leur
nouvelle au centre d'entraînement et en
fait quid de la suite pour les clubs les
clubs yvelinois est-ce que est-ce que
les moyens que va mettre que va mettre
en oeuvre le département des Yvelines
pour accueillir le Stade Français Paris
au Camp des Loges travaux mise aux
normes mise à jour vont être vont être
déduits des de fonctionnement qui
peuvent qui peuvent ou pourraient être
mis à disposition des clubs des Yvelines
donc c'est pour ça que je suis plutôt
contre et méfiant après il faut que tout
le monde puisse exprimer et le Stade
Français Paris est une très belle équipe
d'ailleurs avec un ancien yvelinois dans
les rangs un ancien versaillé avec Léo
Barrey dans les dans les rangs donc on
se connaît bien et on en parle souvent
voilà c'est simplement est-ce qu'il est
possible de contenter tout le monde
notamment les clubs des Yvelines avec un
projet de cette de cette ampleur là
vous êtes pour oui alors on a tous
compris que Pierre était contre mais
c'était bien bien
ciblée c'était la peur la peur que
Versailles soient dans l'ordre du Stade
Français donc c'est pas trop le duel va
être ça facile
j'étais pas général c'est pas alors il
rappelle c'est vrai qu'il que entre
guillemets ils ont viré la CBB du Saut
du Loup pour récupérer le stade c'était
pas très très galable parce que la CVB
c'était aussi une équipe avec avec une
histoire et ça avait été assez
dramatique ils ont été à la base je
remonterai encore plus loin je vais
quand même le Stade Français avant
c'était le Stade Français CSG puisque le
Stade Français n'est monté en première
division que parce qu'ils ont fusionné
avec le CSG parce que s'ils sont jamais
monté sportivement à l'époque où godzini
est arrivé mcdozini est arrivé et
d'ailleurs tiens lui il avait fait les
frais le juste une petite parenthèse on
parlait tout à l'heure de de l'argent
fait-il les
il a acheté tous les grands joueurs de
partout de Toulon du Racing et tout ça
sur le paillettes sur le papier il
faisait peur à tout le monde et puis sur
le résultat sportif c'était pas bon donc
lui il a vite rebondi et ça c'était
juste la parenthèse mais ils ont quand
même fusionné avec le CSG pour monter en
première division aujourd'hui ils ont
investi le jambon c'est à eux il y a
même plus le CSG ça existe plus ils ont
refait des travaux énormes pour pour les
matchs qui maintenant un joli stade à
l'anglaise et qui est qui est très bien
au niveau partout c'est super chouette
mais de là là où pour un club de rugby
et le rugby est l'essence même ils ont
quand même pas de repères ils ont ils
sont un coup au Saut du Loup un coup
enfin ouais au stade Dominici maintenant
un coup à Jean-Bouin un coup euh si à
Meudon je sais pas s'ils vont encore à
Meudon dans la forêt de Meudon là-bas
alors c'est vrai que pour pour une
équipe de rugby en plus une grande
équipe de rugby il le montre encore plus
cette année parce qu'il deuxième du
championnat et bien il leur faut quand
même une stabilité et je crois que le
camp des Loges
peut-être doit être cette stabilité pour
un club qui qui est qui fait partie des
meilleurs clubs de France voilà Philippe
qui vous a
convainculée
non mais genre je pense que comme disait
pierre c'est sûr par rapport aux autres
clubs faut pas que non plus que ça ça
joue sur les finances des autres clubs
et que voilà ce qu'ils le fait d'être
là-bas mais il joue pas là-bas il
continue à jouer il continue à jouer au
Stade Français c'est pas comme si il
venait jouer au Camp des Loges ils
viennent juste s'entraîner si tu veux
ouais bah déjà là ils ont l'année
dernière je crois ils ont refusé le
projet de la FFR à Pantin le il y avait
un projet immobilier sportif ils ont
refusé d'aller là-bas à Pantin avec la
FFR
ils ont refusé terrain de la de des PTT
et la police et ils ont refusé déjà ce
projet là mais je pense que là ils l'ont
faisait mais je pense que là le le
projet là ce projet là comment tient
tiens tiens la route je veux dire
du PSG est-ce que les Yvelines
enfin des blocs des des budgets pour le
PSG c'est un petit peu
parce qu'il joue pas ici il s'entraîne
donc en déloge mais il joue il joue au
parcours les terrains
entre le département la Fondation PSG
qui permettait à des jeunes de
rencontrer aujourd'hui
économiques c'est plus de 300 millions
par an pour la région Île-de-France
sur investissement mais je peux te dire
donc là je pense pas que les clubs
amateurs Versailles plaisir
Maisons-Laffitte que tu as cité je pense
pas qu'ils aient à craindre la venue du
Stade Français sur le camp des Loges
quand je parle de moyens c'est ne
serait-ce que ne serait-ce que la mise à
disposition de terrain nous nous en soi
pour inclusion rapide
et très proche aussi ils ont le même
problème que Versailles c'est un
problème de de nombre de terrain d'ENT
praticable parce que maintenant
maintenant dès que dès qu'il y a moins
de gouttes de pluie on ferme les
terrains en herbe donc soit on a un
terrain synthétique pour pouvoir
fonctionner Versailles par exemple c'est
deux terrains de terrain disponibles
pour 650 licenciés c'est un casse-tête
monumental et là on pourrait dire
simplement ben tiens est-ce que est-ce
qu'il y a pas des terrains disponibles
parce que ça je parle pas forcément de
de son nom est trébuchant mais des
terrains disponibles pour pouvoir
délester un petit peu certains mercredi
certains samedi sur des plateaux d'école
de rugby
on va devoir avancer dans l'émission
désolé pierre je sais que le sujet vous
tient à cœur vous avez un peu énervé
mais vous revenez de vacances donc tout
va bien ne vous inquiétez pas on va
passer notre page débat
[Musique]
on va parler du Dakar 2023 qui s'est
terminé le 15 janvier dernier on vous le
disait un yvelinois c'est distingué sur
cette course Jean-Pierre Garcin le
copilote originaire de monter son à
terminer une belle 16e place avec le
pilote chinois wozu Zend il termine à
plus de 7 heures du vainqueur Katarina
on écoute la réaction de livinois sur le
plateau de TV 78 les écarts sont très
serrés quoi il y a plus trop de
différence il y a plus de il y a plus
d'arrêts les voitures tombent plus en
panne on fait mon moi je suis pas sorti
de la voiture à part en cas de choc puis
on a fait deux crevaisons je suis jamais
sorti de la voiture avant on s'en sablé
et tout maintenant les voitures sont
tellement performantes qui se passent
plus tout ça au moins devant quoi
derrière bien sûr c'est difficile donc
les écarts sont très très petits entre
tous nos le 15e doit être à 5 minutes
devant nous le 17e à 5 minutes aussi
derrière nous et vous avez pu voir la
magnifique cravate aussi de Grégory col
roulé aujourd'hui alors il voulait
terminer dans le top 15 il termine
finalement 16e est-ce que Jean-Pierre
Garcin a réussi son Dakar 2023 oui oui
unanime Philippe pourquoi bah déjà de
finir 16e c'est je trouve que c'est que
c'est que c'est pas mal je veux dire
c'est son 24e Dakar je sais c'est 24e
24e Dakar je trouve que c'est pas mal
parce qu'il y a quand même beaucoup
et c'est quand même tellement d'aléas je
veux dire mécanique et tout ça que bon
tu pars bon après ce que c'est pull
Paris Dakar je trouve de il y a quelques
années aussi je veux dire d'ailleurs
dans son suivi quasiment jamais sorti de
sa voiture pour réparer à part des creux
quelques crevaisons des petits impacts
mais pas plus parce que bon maintenant
je veux dire ça a tellement
mécaniquement je veux dire c'est c'est
costaud je veux dire mais 16e c'est moi
c'est une très belle performance c'est
une très très belle performance genre
cette admiratif des pilotes du Dakar
que déjà il a fini c'est déjà bien
puisque mais bon alors on revient il l'a
dit lui-même il est quasiment pas les
seuls la voiture je pense quand même que
le Dakar a perdu quand même de sa
superbe lui-même mais ça a perdu sa
superbe les tracés sont beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins dur qu'avant qui ne
l'était il a bien avant donc forcément
il y a beaucoup moins de casse certes on
dit que c'est plus solide enfin ils ont
pas révolutionné le le sport automobile
et les véhicules sont pas dix fois plus
solides c'est surtout que les les
parcours les tracés sont beaucoup moins
compliqués beaucoup moins difficiles ou
beaucoup moins accidentogène et
forcément ben il y a beaucoup moins de
casse il y a beaucoup moins de
d'ennuisement il y a beaucoup moins tout
simplement donc après c'est plus une
course j'irai je vais pas dire qu'une
course pépère non plus mais c'est ça le
plus rien à voir le Dakar tel qu'on a pu
le connaître avec toutes les péripéties
qui entouré cette compétition de
prestige voilà maintenant le finir c'est
déjà une belle performance et c'est ce
que je souligne avant tout et en plus au
vu du scénario du Dakar il a eu des gros
problèmes sur sur la voiture ils ont eu
sur la 2e étape il me semble
crevaison
qui a eu quelques problèmes sur sur les
dernières compétitions qui a été
difficile à gérer au final bah 16e place
alors juste une place derrière son
objectif qui était top 15 pour sa 24e
participation maintenant faut pas
oublier aussi que c'était une première
participation avec le pilote chinois
Goyo Zang c'était une une nouvelle
collaboration il n'avait jamais il s'est
jamais rencontré avant le Dakar c'était
rencontré que par visio ils avaient
préparé le Dakar à distance sur place
bah au lieu de Zang visiblement par les
pas très bien anglais donc c'était un
peu difficile à communication en dehors
des
et ça ça c'est plutôt pas mal parce que
lui c'est un pilote confirmé qu'il a il
a roulé comme un fou en tout cas
Jean-Pierre Garcin repartira normalement
l'année prochaine pour
25e 25e Dakar l'année prochaine pour
l'instant il sait pas encore il sait pas
encore alors s'il va repartir mais il
dit qu'à chaque fois c'est toujours ça
les premiers jours il hésitent et deux
semaines après il dit ok je repars donc
pour l'instant c'est pas avec qui on
partira les revenus de son Dakar il
voulait plus et quand il était venu sur
le plateau il nous a dit non j'ai
retourne parce que voilà c'est c'est
dans son essence on part ici la
couverture médiatique est un petit peu
plus faible aussi d'aller en année
dommage sauf chez nous bien sûr alors
vraiment d'en parler football et d'un
footballeur que tout le monde connaît
autour de cette table Zlatan Ibrahimovic
invité de la matinale de France Inter
dans le cadre de la promotion d'Astérix
et Obélix l'Empire du milieu où il joue
un rôle l'ancien joueur du Paris
Saint-Germain s'est exprimé sur la la
finale de la Coupe du Monde il a fustigé
le comportement des joueurs argentins il
a dit je suis inquiet pour les autres en
Argentine parce qu'on se souviendra de
Messi mais les autres qui se sont mal
comportés on ne peut pas respecter ça
pour moi qui parle en tant que joueur
professionnel de haut niveau c'est un
signe que vous ne gagnerez jamais plus
une seule fois de plus on gagne pas
comme ça il est pas quand même Messi
dans dans ce qu'il dit la question sur
cette thématique a-t-il raison
d'attaquer autant ces argentins
Philippe
en plus en venant de lui il est quand
même c'est quand même il a il a quand
même quelque chose derrière je veux dire
comme en 2015 lors d'un d'un c'était
d'un Bordeaux d'un Bordeaux PSG qui
l'avait dit
le pays la France d'une équipe de une
comme un pays de ne pas mais bon voilà
il a quand même dit plus tout ce qu'il a
une précision
voilà non mais je veux dire voilà bon ça
vient de lui en plus là il y a Agüero
dans l'ancien joueur de l'ancien joueur
argentin aussi qui l'a qui l'a taclé
c'est qu'à te le dire tacler dans la
dans la presse aussi que dire que les
dernières années il a il avait rien à
dire parce que lui il a il a jamais
participé à la Coupe du monde les deux
ou trois dernières édition il a pas
participé bon après voilà c'est du
Zlatan c'est du Zlatan voilà pour moi
c'est ça c'est bien plutôt étonné par le
par le moment qu'il choisit pour pour
mettre un pavé dans la barre parce que
on est tous d'accord la promotion
ça sort un peu nulle part là c'est sans
doute aussi pour plaire au marché
français au marché du cinéma français et
donc du football français donc bon le
timing est peut-être un peu mercantile
je suis un peu étonné quand même après
sur le problème je crois de mémoire
pendant toute la compétition et l'équipe
d'argent sur le propos on est tout on
est tous unanime c'est c'est
effectivement le comportement des le
comportement des Argentins pendant et
après la finale a manqué clairement
d'élégance je parle même pas je parle
même pas du du gardien et des gestes des
gestes obscène du gardien au moment de
la remise de son trophée de bien gardien
de la compétition facile c'est des trucs
c'est lunaire c'est absolument lunaire
donc là dessus il a raison de la à dire
après ils gagneront plus jamais rien
parce que parce qu'il manque d'humidité
on est si l'humilité faisait perdre
ça ça saurait où est-ce qu'elle faisait
gagner même aussi ça serait aussi hein
moi je suis d'accord avec Philippe sur
l'aspect Zlatan c'était pas le premier
enfin c'était pas le dernier pardon à
chambrer c'était le c'est un gros
chanbreur on connaît c'est zlatanerie
c'est ses petites punchlines qui
zlatanaient d'ailleurs qui rentrait dans
le dictionnaire français voilà on
connaît les punchlines de Zlatan
Ibrahimovic donc de se permettre de dire
que d'autres Charris bon après sur le
fond oui bien sûr que les Argentins sont
allés trop loin ils n'ont pas eu la
victoire honorable on va dire déjà bah
c'était quand même une grande joie pour
ce pays depuis Diego Armando Maradona
1986 c'était la dernière Coupe du Monde
de revenir gagner après tant d'années
plus de plus de oh là je suis très
mauvais en calcul 30 ans plus tard plus
de 30 ans plus tard
27 oui 27 ans 27 ans
oui voilà ils auraient pu juste se
contenter de comment dire de cette
victoire et fêter plutôt que d'aller
vanner les Français en plus il y a ils
ont beaucoup Vané qui gagnent mapper qui
a quand même mis juste un triplé en
finale
donc bon enfin voilà ça joue pas si la
dernière occasion passe et on a plus on
a passé polémique ouais et après par
contre je suis pas d'accord aussi avec
lui sur il épargne Messi ben Messi a
quand même cautionné les les comment
dire taquinerie des miliano Martinez sur
le bus ou Emmanuel Martinez porte un
poupon avec le visage de mappé mais si
juste à côté c'est quand même son père
voilà
il l'a pas vu soit disant il a peut-être
pas utilisé les mêmes mots que Martinez
mais en tout cas enfin il aurait pu
aussi dire attention tu vas un peu trop
loin quoi voilà il aurait pu aussi
sortir publiquement pour dire il faut
quand même respecter Mbappé qui qui a
été un valeureux adversaire en finale de
cette Coupe du Monde genre qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez c'était 36 ans
très mauvais en calcul on l'a vu
on l'a tous vu
non moi ce qui on va pas revenir sur ce
qui a été dit on condamne tous le
comportement les Argentins c'est sûr
maintenant voilà je vais vous dire que
ce que ça vient de la part des mecs
Zlatan Ibrahimovic alors là moi ça me
fait hurler de rire et puis c'est
surtout quand même que ce milieu fait
dans ce sport il passe leur temps à se
chambrer à se bat pas se respecter et là
on est outré parce que les mecs ils font
le truc certes la finale c'est surtout
parce que c'est la France ils ont battu
quoi c'est ça surtout que ce qu'il nous
fout les boules c'est pas spécialement
le comportement des comportement dans le
foot mais il y en a constamment des
comportements qui sont complètement
aberrants donc bon un de plus un de
moins mais surtout pas que lui il vient
de nous dire que lui c'était
inadmissible tout ça lui convient
comment il était lui quand il jouait
l'homme il faut arrêter c'est lui
d'ailleurs
il avait demandé un joueur c'est quoi
ton nom je te connais pas
elle a toujours été respectueux
[Musique]
n'importe quoi
de lui faire et donc du cinéma
maintenant
26 ans et demi on vient de me dire en
régie 26 ans et demi donc je sais pas
qui qui a raison qui a tort on va dire
je n'ai pas ma calculatrice
apparemment les comptes sont mauvais en
régie aussi
vous pouvez passer aux lettres alors on
continue à parler football on termine
par l'une des images insolites de la
semaine dernière c'était jeudi dernier
l'équipe du PSG a visité le futur centre
d'entraînement à Poissy l'occasion pour
l'ensemble du groupe parisien de voir
l'avancée des travaux on a pu voir
Mbappe Messi ou encore Neymar en tenue
de chantier dans des vidéos la livraison
de la structure et programmée dans le au
courant de l'année 2023 elle comprendra
17 terrains de football des hébergements
restaurants ou encore un spa l'équipe
première devrait s'y entraîner à partir
de cet été tout simplement parce que
vous en pensez de cette visite de des
Parisiens
tenu déjà dit Monsieur
les travaux sur leur temps de leur temps
libre ou
sans les visiter l'avancée du chantier
et du coup bah en tenue réglementaire
avec le casque classique
parce qu'ils ont fait c'est parce que
comme il y a
OM PSG là et que Neymar il ramasse
toujours des choses tu sais sur la tête
à chaque fois qu'il va tirer les corner
et ben là il a un casque ils ont un
casque il va pouvoir les jouer ils vont
pour le garder quand ils vont aller
alors à l'orange Vélodrome je dis bien
c'est c'est livraison avec un an et demi
de retard je crois que par rapport à ce
qui était prévu brusquer en terme de
travaux à peu près la norme donc pas
trop trop de problèmes c'est une c'est
vraiment faut voir la photo
avec avec les les trois là nos trois
compères qui sont plus
erratiques qui sont absolument ravis
d'être là ils sont franchement mais très
très contents d'être sur cette photo là
bon après les entrées mise à part cet
endroit là ça va être ça va être un
centre d'entraînement flambant neuf
high-tech je passe devant quasi toutes
les semaines c'est un c'est un très très
beau produit et c'est un là aussi je
pense une un produit d'appel pour les
d'abord pour le PSG mais peut-être qu'il
y aura aussi d'autres équipes sportives
qui pourront en profiter dans les années
à venir c'est très bien pour les
Yvelines c'est très bien pour Poissy
d'avoir ce d'avoir ce type d'équipement
à proximité et d'avoir une équipe de de
l'image du PSG en résidence entraînement
là là on en parle encore une équipe
parisienne
je pense que je pense qu'on va on va le
payer on va le payer
un bel écran pour pour parisien qui est
là sympa bon là on l'a pas vu l'image
mais si l'image sympa on les voit c'est
un moment de vie entre ils étaient
contents ou pas je sais pas d'être là
ils ont répondu à quelques interviews ça
nous a permis aussi de voir un peu les
avancées de l'intérieur parce que c'est
vrai qu'on passe souvent en proximité on
avait du mal
les tous premiers travaux mais c'est
vrai de rentrer dedans pour voir
l'avancée là on a vu qu'il y a encore
très secret voilà il y a quand même des
bâtiments qui sont sortis de terre
heureusement puisque normalement ils
vont
occuper les lieux à partir de la saison
de la saison prochaine sachant que Stade
Français va arriver donc on a vu que la
pelouse commençait les pelouses et 14
terrains de football commençaient à
pousser à pousser tranquillement voilà
tout n'est pas encore en place des armes
aussi ouais
tout autour
il y a du jus de pomme du Paris
Saint-Germain
donc non ça permet de voir l'avancée des
travaux et effectivement bah écran de
dernière génération et qui sera à la
hauteur de de toutes les ambitions que
que porte le PSG alors les images vous
avez vu les gens du PSG avec leur petit
casque de chantier vous avez pensé quoi
Grégory notamment verratti ou qui est un
fan du sport italien
tout à fait tout à fait crédible en chef
de chantier Marco verratti euh très très
sympa non non une image sympa à voir
c'est un coup de un coup de projecteur
un coup de pub je crois que deux jours
avant ils étaient pas contents ils
étaient venus en chasse du jaune parce
que Galtier les avait privés de un jour
et demi de congés en plus donc et ça
venait après alors bon c'est un coup de
pub un coup de sachant qu'on sait pas le
nombre de joueurs qui pourra qui seront
là l'année prochaine pour commencer à
l'utiliser tu vois donc mais si sur les
images nous sommes un petit peu blasés
peut-être qu'il sera pas présent en
l'année prochaine au Paris Saint-Germain
on sait pas encore c'est bien pour un
club comme PSG d'avoir comme tous les
grands clubs ils ont un centre
d'entraînement voilà mais est-ce que je
me dis est-ce que ce centre
d'entraînement sera encore fera l'amour
personne pourra y rentrer ça va pas aux
Yvelines noix pourront pas aller le
visiter pourront pas faire des trucs et
ben je veux dire c'est dommage que s'il
y a pas ça pour les Yvelines noires ça
sert à rien si c'est si c'est voilà
fermé qu'on peut pas y aller et ça fait
je pense qu'en termes de choix dans la
date on est dans un timing parfait pour
pour les dirigeants du Paris
Saint-Germain parce que c'est vrai que
les résultats sportifs en ce moment du
PSG ne sont pas fixe depuis la le retour
du PSG sur le terrain en 2023 il y a eu
deux défaites un match nul la
dernièrement contre Reims ça permet de
parler d'autre chose que des résultats
en dentier pour le PSG justement la
Ligue des Champions est-ce que vous êtes
optimiste par rapport au match contre le
Bayern - Jean
alors on va dire le PSG quoi on ne sait
pas c'est comme ça ils sont le Bayern a
réussi
à prendre deux joueurs pendant le
mercato et et
puis j'ai à loupézillac dans un vraiment
est-ce que c'est Chelsea qui a pas voulu
et tout ça y est c'est quand même un
truc inadmissible par rapport à un grand
club comme ça de se faire avoir à 10
minutes près de pas avoir les les
papiers signés
alors c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission a terminé comme d'habitude par
une citation aujourd'hui je vous propose
une citation de Novak Djokovic qui vient
de remporter son 22ème titre du Grand
Chelem le tennis n'est pas qu'un sport
c'est une façon de vivre donc fais-en ta
vie joue à fond travail dur et
entraîne-toi je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]